okay we'll get started straightaway
thank you so much everybody for being
here to the press conference after the
adoption by the College of the
Commission's proposals for the revised
methodology to enhance the accession
process and given the that we have very
limited time and Commissioner will make
a presentation then we'll have time for
some questions but I would please like
to ask you to keep the questions to the
topic because out of respect we don't
have too much time and Commissioner has
to go to effect so please Commissioner
yeah sure
thank you very much thank you very much
for showing interest in what we do today
the college has adopted a new
methodology for the accession
negotiations this is the first element
in a renewed enlargement strategy this
new commission is coming forward with
the second element in in our discussions
is also going to be about launching the
accession negotiations with North
Macedonia and Albania and the third one
is going to be a major economic
development plan for the entire region
which we hope that the Zagreb summit can
endorse now the purpose of the of
today's proposal is to reestablish the
credible EU perspective for the Western
Balkans and to make it very clear that
for the Commission and for the EU as a
whole it is a top priority to have
stability peace and prosperity in our
region and in that of course enlargement
is a key political project which is a
firm merit-based and full membership
prospect for the entire region
this is geo geo strategic investment
that we all need to make and we hope
that the Member States will be partners
in this this is why we have revisited
the discussions that we have seen in
October that unfortunately it did not
result in opening accession negotiations
for the two countries so we have been
reaching out to try to address the root
causes of the failure while not
compromising on any of the principles
that underline the enlargement process
now the proposal that you see today is a
proposal for a revised accession
negotiations methodology we'll call it
methodology but maybe best would be to
call it process or procedure there are
four principles around which the whole
methodology is based credibility
predictability dynamism and stronger
political steer these are the principles
for which we would want to work these
are the principles that we would like to
ensure both for our member states in our
public but also for the Western Balkan
countries so the whole process would
have to be more credible for the both of
us it has to be more predictable more
dynamic and more political it means also
that we need to improve and strengthen
the process and that we continue to have
as a go full enlargement and to have
these members these states welcomed as
full EU member states of the union now
we looked at how to improve the chances
of of these new states all of these
states becoming member states and we
have seen that we have to improve the
delivery of the reforms in the region
this is a concern that has been raised
by very many member states not only
those
who were critical or who have been
opposing but a much larger number of
member states we need we need reforms to
last reforms to work in this region and
that will create also the freedom for
the people but also more sustainable
more resilient economy for the entire
region now if I want to go one by one in
the principles what I see is that under
the what I can tell you is that under
the credibility principle our end of war
is to make it very clear what we mean
what we require from these accession
countries and what is it that we offer
if they if they deliver we want to
reestablish solid trust and mutual
confidence between the Western Balkan
and us and our member states but also in
our public we need to make it clear that
if the reforms are further strengthened
and mainstreamed we will be able to
deliver also on our side it also means
that we will continue with the
merit-based approach and only a
merit-based approach therefore
assessment of the progress is key and
the reinforcement of the assessment is
key the poorer the stronger political
steer would be best served if we have at
all political level a more constant
dialogue with the region but also if we
had more a political reflection on the
achievements of these countries and
therefore we would like the leaders of
the European Union to have at least an
annual debate about the progress these
countries I'm making this could be based
on the Zagreb summit we would like to
include them at top-level ministerial
level engagements at all areas where
these countries are participating
fully for example in the horizon 2020
when ministers are discussing in the
council the future of the horizon 2020
or the usefulness of the horizon 2020
these states should also be invited to
be part of the discussion so that they
know and see what it is required when
you are a member state the other element
is in political steer is that we have to
include more in the Member States when
it comes to the monitoring of the
progress this is why we want to make
better use of the Assessor
of the Association institutions the
Association Council on Association
committee and the mixed parliamentary
committee where we will have the
opportunity to have real dialogue about
the progress made but also about the
tasks to be delivered now the more
dynamic process is best characterized by
the grouping of the accession chapters I
understand that this is very technical
but if I want to if I want to make it
clear what we are doing is that we group
the themes the issues together that
belong together so we will have six
groups of issues in which we will be
conducting these negotiations it means
also that these negotiations will be
much more overarching much more
comprehensive that should also create an
incentive on the side of the session
countries to accelerate their reforms
and it should also create the
possibility to move faster if they
deliver faster the cluster chapters the
clustered chapters also bring about
reinforcements of the rule of law
conditionalities which means that we
will open with the rule of law cluster
and we will close with the rule of law
cluster the accession negotiations this
will ensure that this issue will be
continuously monitored and looked at
during the during the whole process the
maybe for the Western Balkans a very
important offer that we are making with
the cluster system is that if they are
ready with the reforms by the time we
start the accession the negotiations on
the cluster we are ready we will only
have to discuss the implementation of
their key
we are ready on our side to make
everything to conclude these chapters
that belong to the Craster within one
year this is an offer from our side but
the little but the delivery has to come
from the other side this way we can
really speed up things given that these
days we see that it takes six to eight
years to close one chapter of the
negotiations now lastly but maybe most
importantly predictability
predictability means that we have to
have clearly defined conditions so that
we both know what it is required and
when it is achieved this is why we will
flash out much more in detail all the
criteria and condition we put to these
countries to achieve and this is why we
want to involve all the member states in
the monitoring of these achievements we
need them to share their analysis with
us so that we avoid any last-minute
surprises surprises that we have seen
already three times before and this is
why it should be more inclusive for them
I don't hide the fact that one of the
most difficult issues when we were
putting together the package was that it
is clear that in our public opinion and
in our Member States there's very strong
call that we need to be able to reverse
also the negotiations when there is no
progress or when there is backsliding
clearly we also have to apply similar
similar measures meaning that we have to
make it clear that we can also go
backwards so if countries fail to
deliver or do back reforms on our side
similar actions will be taking when it
comes to the accession the accession
process now after the the communication
will come revised set of reports on
north Kassadin in albania hopefully
still this month and we are working now
to accelerate the progress in these two
countries so that we can have a decision
on opening accession negotiations still
before the zagreb summit I think a death
stage I I stopped here and I would be
happy to answer any of your questions